people even now because it's like the
hundredth anniversary of the Russian
Revolution or celebrating Lenin it's
like that's not good
that's like celebrating Hitler okay I'm
dead serious about that it's not good
and the fact that people can dare to
think that that's okay means that
there's something wrong with the way
that we look at history Lenin was a
monster and if you want to know about
that you can read Solzhenitsyn's
writings about Lenin because they
communist apologists say well I wasn't
Lenin Lenin was a good guy
he was all motivated by love of the
working class it's like well his
henchman was Stalin and if your henchman
is Stalin you're not a good guy and and
Lenin was around during the early
collectivization and if you read what he
wrote you'll find out that he was
perfectly willing to have any number of
people die as long as his ideological
system could be brought into being so
there's no celebrating Lenin there's no
work cool young Marxist hip
revolutionaries and he's our Idol it's
like there's none of that not if you
know anything not if you're decent well
there was death of the cool acts I told
you about that there was the Ukrainian
famine that's 6 million gone there there
was the rise of the gulag state because
it turned out that Russia the Soviet
Union couldn't run on the principles
that it had that it had laid down as
sacrosanct they just didn't work so you
had enslaved everybody and run your
economy as a slave state essentially and
try not to kill the people in the gulags
so fast that you can't suck some
productive labor out of them was the
death of tens of millions of people we
don't even know the estimates range from
15 to 60 million and like we won't get
to Picayune about the numbers because
after the first 10 million you kind of
made your point and the fact that we
don't know between 15 and 60 is actually
an indication of the horror of it
because our count is off by tens of
millions and that's only within the
century and then there was the 1956
crackdown on Hungary and the 1968
invasion of Czechoslovakia then there
was the whole like thermonuclear
Holocaust thing that was going on at the
same time in the fact that in 1962 and
in 1984 we were seconds away from
complete annihilation right during the
Cuban Missile Crisis the keys were in
the intercontinental ballistic missile
release systems and Castro as he
admitted to Jimmy Carter in case any of
you or Castro fans which you shouldn't
be that he was perfectly willing to have
Cuba annihilate it if it would have
meant the defeat of the United States
and then in 1984 approximately I may
have the date exactly wrong the Russians
received an indication from their early
warning systems that the Americans had
launched five thermonuclear missiles and
one Russian decided that it was a
mistake and refused to launch the
retaliation and he just died about two
weeks ago so you know that was pretty
close and so that was experiment number
one let's say that that wasn't good that
experiment let's put it that way it
wasn't good it was exactly the
antithesis of good it was precisely the
antithesis of good but that wasn't all I
mean there's the People's Republic of
China that's a different country like
seriously a different country right
different tradition different language
how many people died in China under Mao
no one knows same issue with the Soviet
Union
although mile was a bigger monster than
Stalin and that's that's impressive you
know because there's Hitler
there's Stalin and there's Mao and of
the 3-mile was probably the worst he's
still revered in China maybe that
accounts for their affinity for North
Korea which could still destroy us all
the remnants of that horrible state
maybe a hundred million people died in
China during the great leap for
that's a hell of a leap forward well
maybe it wasn't a hundred million you
know maybe it was only 40 million but as
I said before when you're counting in
the tens of millions your points already
made and then there was Cambodia and the
killing fields and Bulgaria and East
Germany and Romania and the Democratic
People's Republic of Korea that's North
Korea and Vietnam and Ethiopia Hungary
etc etc etc there was never a successful
communist state Cuba I suppose came
closest but it was radically the Soviets
poured money into Cuba so that doesn't
really count so then the first question
was well are these Marxists motivated by
love or hatred well is it love or hatred
that produces a hundred million dead
people is that enough evidence or not
and if it's not enough evidence if you
think to yourself well that's not enough
evidence it was never really given its
proper a proper try it's like well what
would have been a proper try see I
always think when I hear someone say
that I know what you think you think in
your delusional arrogance that you
understand the Marxist doctrines better
than anyone else ever has and that if
you are the one implementing those
doctrines you would have ushered in the
utopia that's what you mean when you say
that and you know they say and there's
an idea in the New Testament that
there's a sin it's the sin against the
holy ghost
if you commit that sin no one really
knows what it is that you can't be
forgiven and I would say well if you
want a candidate for the sin against the
Holy Ghost in the 21st century
the statement communism real communism
was never tried with the underlying idea
that if you had been the person
implementing it it would have worked
I think that's a pretty good contender
for something for which you should never
be forgiven